all right joining us now with reaction
former White House press secretary Sean
Spicer and former deputy assistant to
the president Fox News national security
strategist dr. Gorka Sean Spicer just
look at these note three million jobs
have been created America now is on a
path towards energy independence he's
gotten rid of more regulations than any
other administration in record time
his tax cut deal is done the the
employer mandate is gone and lo and
behold rocket man's gonna sit down with
the president who would have thunk it
Isis is on the run
border crossings are down the
judiciary's being remained with
conservative judges he's standing up for
life and we could go on and on and on
the president's continuing to rack up
results and one of the things that's
interesting Sean when you touched on
this but the bottom line is is that as
he gets results they try to talk about
chaos and process at the end of the day
most Americans care whether or not their
country and their lives are improving
and they are the president continues to
chalk up results they're making this
country a better place for making it
safer they're making the economy better
giving more people jobs higher wages and
what what people will vote for at the
end of the day is to make their lives
the lives of their family the lives of
their neighbors and the lives that our
fellow citizens better the president's
achieving those results and I think so
what happens is the media that interns
and tries to figure out how can we focus
on the process story how can we talk
about chaos and things like that as
opposed to the results the one thing
that I think is really interesting Sean
is that President Trump is doing exactly
what he said he would do on the campaign
trail
Washington is littered with campaign pot
with politicians that make promises over
and over again and then don't fulfill
them president Trump's doing exactly
what he said he was going to do and he's
getting the results that he said he
would get yeah and after eight years of
Obama 13 million more Americans on food
stamps 8 million more on poverty Louis
labor participation rate since the 70s
worse recovery since the 40s he doubled
the debt lowest homeownership rate in 51
years it's all rebounded in a year and
the tax cuts are only now just kicking
in dr. Gorka that's the most remarkable
thing this is for this is isn't even 14
months
into a trump administration the kinds of
things that this administration has
achieved you'd be proud of them if
you're an eight-year double term
president and insurance absolutely right
look the the obsession with process if
this is chaos Shawn give me more chaos
give all Americans more chaos because
it's bringing the results and at the end
of the day show us America elected a
disrupter yes America elect an
iconoclast no no I don't think most
Americans are going to vote that they
don't like Donald Trump's tweets if they
have 3,000 more dollars in their pocket
a year right look short let's just say
one thing we lived it short and I lived
it inside the building the more they
attacked us and the president the more
we knew we were doing what the people
elected the president to do the one
thing that's interesting though is that
the American people are onto this right
if you look at the ratings that came out
look at the programs where American
people are tuning into they're tuning
out the mainstream news and they're
tuning into shows like yours and Tuckers
and Laura and other shows on Fox because
they're tired of not being told what's
going on the American people understand
what's happening and they're changing
their viewing habits to match with it
what what's being fed to them because
they don't want to see these other
states look this and focus on the
process in the chaos guys thank you Bob